there we go everybody welcome to fairly
normal Josh wolf I'm here with the very
handsome thank you incredibly in shape
yeah youthful youthful tight skinned
vibrant vibrant supple some jungle cat
like mm-hmm Bryan Callen intense in town
oh yeah yeah the intensity just it seeps
out of here I'm looking for a young
Bryan Callen um did I tell you that my
agent called me because they were
looking for a Josh wolf type and said do
you wanna go in on this I was like yeah
I feel like you and I are kind of at the
same level yeah damn wisest in terms of
just like you know always kind of not
famous but just sort of like I would say
I'm the guy that sometimes working after
I do small parts in big films sometimes
yeah and you know what else like when
did why are we at the Josh wolf type
spot when we were never at the Josh wolf
vampire do you know to me like I do you
skipped over the spot where I was
getting those roles and now you're just
going for my type well unfortunately if
I died people would go oh that guy oh
yeah pass the salt would you you are
that guy yeah I win why said to my wife
I was like Bryan Callen over she's like
Bryan Callen I got let me pull a picture
she goes oh that guy and you know what
I'll take it I'm making a living how
long have you been in e1a years 20 years
from work really more from New York so
20 years and so making money for 20
years which is not that yeah some years
good most years good though most years I
mean last year he had a job job 25 years
ago
24:20 yeah something like that and up
until then were you making like when did
you make money you start making money
doing stand-up
not until not it would probably eight
years ago so before that it was all
acting right you did like ivory violet
every time I would just one would look
stand up as in a boom right now you can
make money doing static yes so when we
were auditioning for pilots it wasn't so
well you know III often feel as though I
say to myself I wish I had started I
I'd start doing the road when Rogen and
Bill burr and those guys had done it
because we're all the same age but but
you know I worked so hard at acting and
I really tried so hard and I really
tried to be what I wanted to be as an
actor and I realize looking back on it
that part of it was I choked because I
wanted it so badly a lot of the time
when the big parts would come up so I
failed in that regard but I did work a
lot too
and I think but the other issue was that
I wasn't probably I was more in love
with making people laugh on a set than
actually doing the acting and frankly if
I'm really honest with myself and I look
back at all the jobs I've ever done I
don't think I ever showed up on set and
didn't want it to end
yeah I was always and continue to always
look forward to when we're done acting
on film weight repetitions what you're
saying is you tried like hell to get the
role but when you got the role you were
like when is this over that's right and
that's not good
Bradley Cooper as an example absolutely
loves every detail of acting from how
it's shot to what your belt doing all
that yeah what you're built yeah when I
did the hangover he said dude have your
belt undone like maybe you finished
taking a pee and come out like he gave
me a bunch of things to do give you a
belt note yeah he get but he and he gave
me a bunch of stuff that that worked
like Bradley will direct you while
you're acting because he's so invested
in the film and he loves acting and so
he just wants to help you
he wants to make you look good I hate to
say it but he's a great guy I hate him
handsome a gazillionaire and he speaks
fluent French he does hi your wife is a
dime piece yes she's pretty good like
what a smoke show I know not terrible
that's what happens when you look like
you're a cutie pie with a good
personality he's got it yeah yeah I know
it's not terrible right graduations I
cheekbones yeah I know right
they're pretty good she's a hot brunette
mm-hmm well done I've been pretty well
done to you roofies roofies is what
that's the only way you know how i lured
her in right no you're funny
well I lured her in with with being the
single dad I was dating when the three
hit
the first phone call I had with her I
was making dinner for the kids by myself
so in what she always says the line that
I like she loved she fell in love with
was me saying to my daughter hey Caitlin
what do you want on your turkey burgers
baby and she was like look Wow yeah yeah
I thought there was a dude who knew it
was that easy women let me say some
we've we wasted so many years trying to
come up with these crazy lines I know
he's gonna purr taking turkey burgers
they did an interesting study on men by
I bet they didn't sing study on men
they showed men it had nothing do with
level what they want to see how good a
father a man would make and some men
would leave but what is it what is the
factor of some men leave and they're not
as attentive his father's and and what
what how you find a man who's a good
father and more attentive and is there
and they they did an interesting
experiment where they showed men a
pornographic film actually a woman
dancing naked okay and the men who who I
first they showed I'm sorry first they
showed the men children pictures of
children and they have them play with
some children or something then they
showed the man in a Jared somewhere no
no then they showed the men some hot
woman dancing and the men whose
testosterone spiked were the men who
were most likely to not be good fathers
when they saw the woman dancing yes they
met but that when the testosterone
didn't spike or even stayed the same
they always those with ones that made
the best fathers so it had nothing to do
with where you start testosterone wise
its what the image of a dancing woman
does to you and what your test run did
what your levels are after that will
determine according to this study I
don't know if I buy into that well it's
just one study but it was interesting I
think was in The Wall Street Journal of
The Economist The Economist did a
experiment let me just say this is why
to me you are one of the most
fascinating guys out there and if you
haven't seen
you're stand-up it's ridiculous it's a
it's it's ridiculous yeah and what I
love about you is that you deliver
ridiculous lines that cannot be true
with extreme confidence yes I'm a liar
but but with such precision confidence
right so your standup is silly
you're an ultra-intelligent dude I don't
there I don't know about that you're
very well-read yes okay in comparison to
I'm well-read in comparison to a lot of
people in Los Angeles and more comics
yes okay but I would also tell you that
that you're quoting The Economist that
takes us that's probably a small
percentage of this country would you say
that probably why do you feel like and
I'll tell you I kind of do it not to the
same level that you do it why do you
feel like do you feel like you dumb
yourself down on stage no I don't I you
know when we talk about lying for me
everything I do on stage is true in fact
in what I mean by that is that if I'm
talking about giving myself a butter
bath or riding a horse with long hair
kind of moved on from that but but but
that's all how I want to be that that's
great ingrained in a great deal of truth
so there's there's most of my life is
spent wishing our somewhere someone else
right that's a very different
perspective and probably a different
mindset I have another facet to my
personality which is that I think
understanding why and how the world
works and being politically and
philosophically committed to something
is very important for a man and frankly
for a citizen and I think because
otherwise you become a tool and so part
of the problem I think it's important to
know why someone like Donald Trump is
damaging I also think it's important to
know why Donald Trump has a point of
view I think it's also important to know
why where he does add value and where he
detracts and when I think it's important
rather than say I don't like Donald
Trump I think it's better to say I I
think he does more
harm than he does good at this stage
it's kind of like when you speak about
being a Republican or Democrat the
problem with coming to a discussion
saying I'm a Republican or I'm a
Democrat or I'm left-wing or I'm
right-wing is that you are immediately
fixing yourself as a noun
yeah but you know what else with those
particular now yeah is that especially
in today's society if I say Republican
comes with a bunch of baggage
presupposition yes and when you say
Republican everybody assumes far right
it is well there's an offensive yes and
like not a defensive but an offensive
point of view rather than coming to
something as in neutral it's a little
bit like saying I'm a Jew I'm a Catholic
yes when I say when somebody says I'm a
Jew or somebody says I'm a Catholic
it comes with we you know it comes with
a great deal of labels we immediately
say that person must be or could be
pro-life and all these things right but
there are a ton of people and I will
tell you there's some people in my
family who have said well I guess if I
had to check a box it would be
Republican because fiscally yes they're
conservative socially they're very good
points so so this is how exactly and so
this is how I think discussions should
be approached I never say I'm a
Republican or Democrat what I would I
start with is a question which is let's
start the discussion this way to what
extent and and let's even talk degrees
do you think the government should have
control over the choices you make in
your life it should have some control we
do need some government the question is
do you want to give 50 percent of your
money to government do you want to give
forty sixty five percent it's just a pen
right Bernie Bernie Sanders says you
know if you make a lot of money you
should probably spend you know I would
imagine he'd be very happy with taxing
anybody who makes over five hundred
grand
seventy percent of their income yes he
seems to think that works I disagree
with that very much
but I'm not saying that I am a
Republican because Republicans frankly
make it impossible to vote for them cuz
I'm not a I mean a lot of these guys are
just very very Christian and I don't
think
I think that should be a private affair
etc it's at yeah so rather than have
these strong opinions and labels III
like discussing I like saying we have a
problem how do we solve this problem but
we're we're then for those of us and
sounds like you're in that group with me
where since the majority and I think the
majority of us lie somewhere in the
middle mm-hmm why don't let the extremes
bully us right it's always been that way
and and the answer to that question is
probably a deeper question which is
probably because of the way campaigns
are financed now you're getting into
campaign finance reform which is way too
boring for a podcast but it's only the
most important thing we face I mean
frankly if you really want to get into
it the real truth is that if you
actually care about where this country
is headed we should all have a strong
point of view on how campaigns are
financed 100% takes some investigation
and a lot of work Republic lost by
Lawrence Lessig is a good place to start
with that his book so you see now very
well read yeah let me hop on to things
that made me think of you May first you
mentioned Trump yeah and second I want
to get to it kind of went off and how
we're a sound bite society like that is
basically how people win or lose now
right I would even say when you look at
Trump what's interesting to me isn't the
fact that he's winning it's what is the
group that has not felt serviced in this
country that are so vocal like that's
good that's a good question my question
is okay yeah so clearly there's a big
group yeah that has been silent and not
serviced yeah apparently for years
yes who are they so and how do we reach
them outside of try I love that question
because what you're really saying is and
is see there's a tendency to say it's
just a bunch of white working-class
males who are voting for Trump they're
dummies well no they're not dummies I
don't like Trump but the people that are
voting for them are not dummies I agree
they a lot of them have a strong point
of view and and are not dumb they're
angry they're afraid they they need they
feel some
voiceless and so along comes
mouths whose basically the campaign of
impulses that's not my quote and he
comes along and he's an insult machine
and and all about impulse and and he
comes up with these ridiculous things to
say which we would never be able to even
implement legally well the wall around
Mexico sounds great doll thanks so much
for solving any Muslims and I guess we
won't late Malaysian Spears Malaysians
and Indonesians are exactly like Saudi
Arabia Pakistan he's okay he's just he's
just a firebrand
but he's always had him in American
politics but but I think it's important
to say yes the people in Iowa and the
guys you may not know who are farmers
whoever they have a strong point of view
and support Trump they're not dummies
they are they have needs that are not
being met let's figure out what they are
and let's have a discussion that's my
point and so my point is with social
media because we're soundbite let's take
what's happening with Peyton Manning
right now is an example yeah for some
reason we've decided that it's okay to
print something if we're not sure it's
true yeah which is to me dangerous and I
and I have also we were also obviously
look everybody needs ratings CNN when
he's reading so everybody has an opinion
I don't want my news with it personally
for me I don't want my news with opinion
I want my news with facts I'm Jackson
yeah but you take what's happening app
it and Peyton Manning right now the
court of public opinion is more
important than facts and always has been
right yeah but right now the court of
public opinion is this yes right look to
me Twitter is is our generation Salem
witch mob right because you're basically
it's an angry mob and that angry mob
rallies yeah and the best example I
always give is that you remember that
woman a couple years ago on Twitter who
got it before she was getting on a plane
to Africa she sent out a tweet that said
I'm going to Africa hope I don't get
AIDS
Who am I kidding I'm white yes okay yes
now as a comic thanks funny it was a
good joke yeah and you know what it was
it wasn't racist it was pointing out the
fact that black people do not have the
equal yeah I'm not an equal granite
everybody though it was all white people
who rushed liberal white people from the
Northeast
you know art college campuses in
Northeast like places like Williams and
Amherst and stuff are just as bad that's
when they opposite bat they they killed
a woman in Afghanistan and I watched the
video it's very hard to watch
she was rumored to have burned the Koran
27 year old woman she was actually not
she was she was calling out some guys
for selling economy viagra and in this
fortune-teller quote-unquote said she
burn a Quran started a rumor they beat
her with stones
she was so bloody that they couldn't
even burn her clothing they said lit her
on fire they're just awful that mob
mentality everybody wanted to prove how
Muslim they were how much they loved
Islam that they wanted to kill the
heretic with their own stones right and
everybody had to get in there with their
own stone this is a let me prove how
much I you know well we all go oh my god
that's so harmful boy I tell you what I
saw I saw human beings and I see that
I'm sorry I'd say it it's very very it's
very it's it's it's a tough thing to say
but the same mindset exist in our
liberal college we are so intolerant one
person says one quote/unquote offensive
thing to about a woman or a black person
or a white person and they teach yoga
and that's that's offending
sensibilities and we want their jobs
they want their jobs and I can't stand
can I tell you something this was we
were going to a Christmas party and it
was one of those you know when things
were it's a white elephant so you buy a
gift for under 20 bucks you put on and
you pick a number and everyone gets up
great so I had brought we brought our
gift but somebody brought a shape
tumbler we drop a shot glass into and it
you know it's like a sake bomb but it is
built-in right and they were gonna so
the host goes hey you can't put that in
under the tree and was I won't say we
remember my family was like why not they
say well what if somebody's an alcoholic
and he was like okay they said what if
somebody's recovering alcoholics you
might offend them with that gift yeah
and I stepped in I go hey [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you is right if that glass offends of
recovering out then they shouldn't come
out of the house exactly go [ __ ]
yourself you know what if you're a
recovering alcoholic
it's part of what you deal with yes
that's
but here's a deal like looking and
university it was a camera what the
university was in Canada a woman was
teaching I guess dis people with
disabilities yoga yeah and somebody
complained that it was offensive to
teach yoga because it was it didn't
belong to us whites and it was Bob and
they cancelled the program so this is
some neurotic there are some neurotic
students who are the orbital one is the
worse they're the cafeteria was racist
right yes they're the loudest they're
loudest voices yeah they're lunatics
they're not real they don't they don't
think for themselves they're in for a
very rude awakening it's like Christine
summers of did Joe Rogan's podcast and
wrote a book called the war on boys she
said these people are who are studying
who are majoring in gender studies yeah
good luck at the job good luck listen
good luck and [ __ ] [ __ ] Gender
Studies oh I'm so glad she anymore oh
there there are different pronouns now
but you know good luck good luck with
getting a job I know you're so sensitive
it's great that you're studying these
things and I guess the only only Avenue
is is to be an academic at the same
institution and regurgitate the same
ideas that had bear no relevance to the
outside world but here's the thing that
gets me is those people who are so anti
everything that could be offensive also
do not allow people who have an opposite
point of view to feel safe to have their
point look listens the crazy you and I
you and I are like I I have never and
I'm telling you even as a kid I never
thought anybody should be ostracized no
I I I'm telling you my nature if I see
I've always felt for men who felt like
women I remember seeing it as a kid I I
saw a drag queen when I was I think 11
men and he was in Switzerland and I
could tell and I remember feeling badly
for him I wanted him to be protected I'm
the guy I'm just saying Bryan Callen I
know you're the same way I would never
in a [ __ ] million years make anybody
feel human I don't tell gay jokes or
anti gay jokes and never have and
they're I don't like it it doesn't make
me feel good I I've never been I'm not a
prejudiced person
because of the way I grew up maybe it's
because of my nature
whatever the case I never want to hurt
anybody's feelings and god I wanna
humiliate anybody and for whatever
reason I've always been able to
empathize with those that are on the
outside yeah maybe not so much but I
certainly can and so I'd be the first
one to protect them but having said that
these lunatics like I'm allowed to think
that that Caitlyn Jenner who I knew as
Bruce Jennifer six sixty five of his
years my whole life I'm allowed to be
disturbed by that be confused by that be
surprised by that even be kind of like
put off by it
because everybody is celebrating it like
she's so beautiful and isn't it amazing
and she's an incredible woman don't cram
don't cram your new acceptance down my
throat give me a minute I got the
[ __ ] pause well here and go holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] it doesn't make me a bad
person and it doesn't mean I don't want
him or her to be who they really are
you know but they're pointing their gun
to the wrong people I agree and you know
what my thing isn't in and I'm this
bring brings myself to keep looking at
that bullet you're welcome to something
I don't I can't drink US spirits is
enough I love them I just like the way
it looks I like those old bottles
oh the old phonograph yeah so here's my
thing like I I was all for her making
the change and good for her and you see
if you looked at her over the years
you're like oh it's coming like I don't
know right what I hated was look
don't stop telling me how beautiful she
is you know what she looks like
any sixty five year old dude who puts on
a dress sure that's what they look like
but this I that was a thing someone said
isn't she beautiful and I was like I'm
happy for her I'm super glad that she's
living the life she wants to live that
slow down beautiful yeah she's not she's
not beautiful and I'm allowed to say I'm
certainly if you want to be listen if
you're now before what are you talking
no you know you're lying to yourself oh
no and to me course don't say no you're
lying you're lying no she's not
beautiful and that's the thing like that
kind of stuff I mean they did a good job
with all the baby the plastic surgery I
think was 12 hours of surgery I don't
know how what it was but I mean they did
a good job you
she's looking good but better yeah I
mean the hormones whatever it is I you
know it's fine but it's not not my type
no you ever curious though what one of
those man-made vaginas feels like I had
know somebody who [ __ ] one recently
and recently yeah and then it wasn't
even sure wasn't even sure afterwards
but is now like I think I think us bro I
think I [ __ ] a [ __ ]
I know [ __ ] is like what was the I
said I think that you did it on purpose
and that's okay I still do I still do I
don't care we had we've had this
discussion before I've had my brothers
were you know we'd about ladyboys in
Thailand and I'm like look here at the
end of the day smooth face yeah you're
not seeing a penis do you know I was in
a job as a [ __ ] when I was doing
hangover 2 I was in Thailand and I was
with some of the cast and I'm telling
you those ladyboys if you had sex with
one of those lady boys you're not did
you read about the article cuz I'm not
homophobic in the least
did you read about the article about the
guy who was having a threesome with his
buddy I got to bring it up the quote is
hilarious I haven't threesome with the
buddy but they touch balls so he killed
his friend
what so the clients the quote from the
article Brian the quote me I killed his
friend he had to murder him this is what
this is the quote from the article we
were going out we were switching from
ass to mouth from but to mouth and he
went left when he was supposed to go
right and next thing I know we ball to
ball so
we ball to boast this is a homicidal
maniac who's looking for any excuse to
kill human being first of all that's
what he is
I've never been a fan of like the two
guys in one girl because I'm assuming
I'm having sex in that the other guy is
a buddy of mine yeah and I'd start to
laugh do you really mean like for me
it's it it all of a sudden turns into a
funny situation well you see her buddy
dead serious just going to town and I'd
want to start doing bits yeah but so
tights ball to ball and that's the next
thing I know we ball to ball I mean he
killed it killed him
murdered him he shot him he he's happy
he's and listen to him justified he's in
jail now yo yeah black fella yeah well I
don't know how I put that together
because you were like we bought who
needed any excuse and he brushed
scrotums and decided he had to kill him
so this is a this is a guy who was
looking to kill this if you ball the
ball with your buddy yours you're not
killing them no I'm not I know it's a
good story it's a funny thing the next
time the two of you are at a party
you're like you wanna tell them that
nothing not story it's pretty amazing
but here's we go back I got off track a
little bit about the the mob and and the
Twitter mob okay
recently something happened to me I want
to know where your opinion uh you know
have you read an article out there about
how you know on Twitter when when women
say and by the way I understand that
social media is harder for women than it
is for men I don't think there's any
doubt I get a lot of advances on Twitter
in in in autograph lines women squeeze
my ass or they say I'm gonna squeeze
your ass and people always say to me
well why don't you say it's the same for
you it is for women it isn't because I
don't fear what's happening something
there's no they can't rape you there's
no chance I think are stronger they're
not gonna so that's why I think it's
completely different course it for
anyone to say that it's the same for men
and women online you know you're a dumb
you're dummy so it's not the same
however you know there's been a there
was an article about why when
men reply to tweets about well not all
men well not all men that it's dangerous
and I just don't I don't understand how
like as a man who isn't one of those
predators and I would consider myself a
feminist if you looked at the definition
of feminism yeah I am - all right I just
believe in fair play and meritocracy
across the women mini-moon are very
different but I'm not gonna keep a woman
down because she's [ __ ] dumb
no this is Tom I'm not gonna [ __ ] you
idiot you know so there's an article
about how when men respond not all men
and I don't know why like look I'm not
gonna stand up for look white guys have
had a good in this country for a long
time and still continue to yeah we if
you're born a white dude you got a leg
up yeah I always say I was born on 3rd
and told her about home I'm a white
American male in 2050 to make people
laugh newspaper pretty good I won I won
the historical lottery yeah you're doing
pretty well and plus you got a great
body and a great face Dick Armey
keep calling okay but so I got scared to
reply to a friend of mine because I know
I was like other Twitter I was gonna
come but why is do you think it's
different because if I send out a tweet
that said black guys or Mexicans or
women I'd get a [ __ ] ton of things to
say not all black not all Mexican not
all women why is it different for me to
come back and say not all men am I am i
I was like what is it about me am I
missing out on why this I would even
enter the into the fray I wouldn't even
enter the fray cuz it doesn't matter but
I mean you're talking about fair play
now and you're talking about hypocrisy
and I think that first of all the people
that would respond or get engaged in
that are not they're just not that
relevant right and and and frankly I
don't think they're very intelligent and
frankly I think that they're cowards I
think that these people that are
standing up for every little infraction
are a bit cowardly they're not they're
not they don't care really as equality
they care about power they're if they
have a chip on their shoulder and
they're way more interested in scrapping
and doing it in a cowardly manner
they're not really still allowed you to
have power but be a coward I'm touching
my computer better hide the eiu's you're
yeah you know you you write a letter you
organize a whole you know a movement
against you know something or other I
mean you know I think there are
movements that matter I think if I was
black and I had experiences see black
men probably have a very different
experience with cops on ie person and
I'm never gonna say I know what it's
like to be a black guy it's [ __ ] no
way and I'm sure I would be frustrated
and I'm sure I would have a very
different point of view on black lives
matter for example or whatever so I stay
way out of that stuff yeah I don't like
getting involved in stuff I don't
understand I don't understand what it's
like to be a black man but I do know
it's a lot tougher generally and I don't
care what anybody says and look at the
history of this country it's a lot
harder and there's a lot harder and more
humiliating and a thousand other things
than it is to be white and anybody says
otherwise should pick up a [ __ ]
history book you know so I I I just I
stay out of that man if anything I will
you know I'll tell you something I I
always laugh at this but I secretly root
for black people and I'm not knocks I'm
a liberal and I cuz I like black people
more I just believe in fair play and I
and if you pick up if you read this
history it's been so hard to be black it
just as long and I just like when they
win I I do and I'm not a liberal man
I'm not some left-wing liberal I just
like when they win I just like seeing
like a young black guy who's kicking ass
and setting a good example and he's got
money and he's and he's you know and
he's talented like there are a lot of
people like that was your [ __ ] you're
somewhere where I would hope and I feel
like I am the same way where our group
think would get a little louder like you
are hunter yes yeah okay so you in a lot
of ways
not until you hunt right but you own a
gun yeah two guns and so in a lot of
ways right so are they my liberal
friends think I'm Republican and my
conservative friends think I'm Democrat
Yeah right yeah where is where is that
libertarian right so why
why can't we be louder and stronger
we've already won partially we're how do
we just just because they you know as
again white males yeah the system is
already bucked in our favor thing about
being me and then you're like get it
pretty good I'm gonna stay quiet pretty
well represented if you look at the
candidates in this field yeah pretty
well represented and so in a sense we
we've won and have been winning for a
long time yeah there's not a whole lot
to buck against if anything again it's
like guys like you and I will root for
the people that don't have a voice and
we secretly like when we see a black guy
doing well like I do I just like seeing
me too I love when I see like a black
doctor I was down in Atlanta and I see
like just like these black professionals
cigars in their mouths with [ __ ]
suits and they got money and they roll
up in a Benz and their doctors their
psychiatrist their [ __ ] lawyers I
love that [ __ ]
it makes me feel good about the world
I'm like I'm just talking about justice
I'm where because there's nothing more
tragic than wasted potential
yeah the drug war is decimated a lot of
the black community also for me listen
the one thing that scares me about
watching all these debates is that the
thing to me that's the most important
they don't talk about enough education
like I don't understand how we can have
all these debates culture but you get
back to education man education
education has to be held in high regard
by your culture agreed and there are
cultures in this country that don't hold
education to a premium it's the nobody
wants to talk about that but it's the
most important thing yeah it's alright I
do want to talk about you for a little
bit yeah and you don't seem like that
important but you've but who you are
like you seem to have a thirst for
knowledge yes yeah where do you think
that comes from my father and also
growing up all over the world until I
was 14 and realizing that I was
privileged in places like India in Yemen
inside of your people why you traveled
around my father was a banker and seeing
and being behind in a car a
chauffeur-driven car and watching
children come who are my age come to
your window starving and begging in
Africa like in Kenya when I gave these
people my box lunch and they ripped it
apart trying to get to it they were so
hungry I remember that very well
Albie I was from the age of 0 to 14 and
I came to boarding school but I was
always safe I was American I had plenty
to eat I was clean I had parents that
loved me
and I at a very early age asked why am I
so lucky what what is it about these
countries that doesn't work and that
stuff is answered those questions by the
way are answered in 2 good books that
have different points of view Guns Germs
and Steel by I think that both Pulitzer
Prize winning books but one is Guns
Germs and Steel by Jared Diamond most
reading for everybody listening to this
and why nations fail by Daron Acemoglu
and another professor from Harvard great
books and take a diametrically different
point of view on why that happens but
mainly I believe I'll tell you what it
is I always felt like I owed it to the
people who suffer too at least you know
given the opportunity and the reason I
want to know why is I guess I want to
load up on I want the ammunition to
fight people that want to make the
situation worse and I want to know how
to make it better I believe not - this
is gonna sound like I'm patting my part
I don't mean to do this but I think that
my thirst for knowledge comes from my
compassion I care about the world and I
want the world and the problems in the
world to be fixed and I don't know how
to do it there's nothing more
frustrating today but at least I can
suffer a little at least I can lose some
sleep about what happens to people in
Goma in the Congo or or you know at
least I have an idea of what the
political situation is in Nigeria and I
can have a conversation with a cab
driver and say hey listen you matter
err I don't know I don't know what else
to do that in do you when you gather
this now let's when you gather this
information you keep it for you I don't
know I talk about it a little bit it's
frustrating I can't find enough avenues
and frankly I don't think I am
articulate enough for you are taking I
don't know if I know enough to
necessarily make enough of a difference
but at least I can say hey everybody it
may not seem like your problem but you
know I will tell you that I doubt Isis
would have come about without our
brilliant decision to invade Iraq
there's no doubt and and you had you had
people like George W and his neocon
friends like Richard Perle and Paul
Wolfowitz and and William Kristol and
all these guys I know the people you
know that were the architects of this at
least the intellectual that created the
intellectual scaffolding for this and
they in my opinion didn't understand the
history of the Middle East well enough
but their hubris in believing they could
restructure the Middle East yeah is what
led to this mess and I don't know how
many countless lives lost I don't know
if history will prove me right or wrong
but I think it's important to know that
stuff so that we don't make the same
mistake agreed
do you feel like and this is one of the
things that I was kind of getting at
earlier you know my Who am I on stage is
silly and kind of dumb and because any
time as a comedian you have a point of
view people like it's almost like they
don't want to hear that from there yeah
I mean look like they don't want to hear
that from like their their
compartmentalizing who they're allowed
to hear certain information yeah I mean
I Greg exactly for me look I have a I'm
pretty funny okay I don't care what
anybody says I'm pretty good at comedy
yeah and you know they come they come to
my show and pay lots of money and get a
babysitter and everything else and they
want to laugh hard for an hour in ten
minutes I give them I get it you do more
than an hour I get it thank you for an
hour and 44 minutes I'm gonna give them
the hour and 44 they walk two hours
- I got a bag of tricks I got a lot of I
got a lot of common goals in my quiver
what you need to understand is that they
don't want to be lectured on [ __ ] up
why nations fail and why Guns Germs and
Steel is an important book but but I can
at least my humanity I think and how I
how much I care about people you know
what I love about comedy it brings
everybody together I agree with that
they all laugh you know what people ask
me with what they think the hardest part
of stand-up is and I would tell you the
hardest part isn't now when the people
who are in that room came to see you the
hardest part is when you're in a room
full of people who maybe the rooms been
papered and so you got 400 people in
there who aren't there to see you yeah
they have different likes and dislikes
and you're gonna get they've had
different days they've had different
experiences some are in bad moods summer
in good moods you know they come from
different backgrounds and you get 400
people who don't know each other to
laugh at the same thing yeah right to me
those are the universal questions yes
those are the big to me that was harder
it's easier now I always feel like you
have the the audience's that are there
to see you you have 10 or 15 minutes to
be bad up front yeah there they will
forgive you that I don't know what
that's like
you know what has been amazing to me is
that you've always had a certain energy
around you you still have the energy but
you seem way calmer just a 48 it's just
you know I think it's just being do you
feel calmer no I I get I'm more afraid
now I get more afraid and more I get so
negative about like I hear these things
like these cartels and what they do to
people in Mexico and stuff and I just
you know when I when there's so many
problems I feel like I have no power to
fix or so I don't it drives me crazy but
why don't you and this is what I have
really tried to do by the way one of the
reasons that I do this podcast is
because I've been a strange crossroads
where I've never felt more confident
with who I am and lost at the same time
that make sense it's not a bad thing I
think we remember what Socrates said
right and Socrates said the
consider the wisest man of all he said
at the end of his life essentially I am
the wisest of all men because I
essentially know that I know nothing you
know this is a guy who had all the
answers and would prove it with math I
mean you know if you read the symposium
and the dialogues and he was a guy who
at the end you know at the end of the
day said you know really I don't know
anything Wow yeah I know I told you guys
I knew everything he turns out I don't
know anything he was being falsely
modest because I think he did know ever
maybe he was just trying to [ __ ] with me
can you man can you imagine like there's
this dude who everybody thinks is the
smartest guy in the world and the last
thing he says before he dies is I was
just kidding yeah what yeah what the
[ __ ] well when he was dying you know is
his disciples we're all crying and he's
gonna die and he said if I taught you
guys nothing III do your mourning my
physical the physical machine that
harbors my soul my soul is going on but
my don't what are you crying about that
this is just this is just shitty
machinery it's kind of a cool way to I
won't be that brave no well no no I mean
yeah Socrates was the bulldozer Socrates
was if you hit me he was so as you read
him as a young man and as and any man
you realized oh my god the
responsibility of being a real human
being is never goes away I don't care
was 3,500 years ago now in terms of the
fact that he essentially would show you
me and you immediately we live on a
house of glass we're just living in the
house of cards we have no foundation for
how we live we're just going by instinct
feel what we were told and we don't
really question things and he would say
well why are you doing this but having
said that you and I and many of us
probably listening are direct directly
beneficiaries of the thinking both he
Plato and Aristotle did yeah you know
when you read a lot of it now you go
yeah that's how I feel well that's
because our system of government and our
vocabulary everything is based on a lot
of that I you know what's interesting is
that did you read going clear yeah okay
oh yeah you know what I took away from
that was in that they didn't show in the
documentary was that if you took the
religion out of it before he got greedy
and just if he had come out as the first
Tony Robbins is the first self-help guy
a lot of at [ __ ] makes sense yeah you
know what I mean like I was reading a
lot of it like that makes sense to me
the complete make a complete sense it's
when he went to the religion and he got
a little greedy with his money yeah
that's when the kind of loopy er alien
volcano [ __ ] came up but his principles
yeah I think he I think he probably went
crazy he lost his mind and from what I
from the is that what it was yeah okay
so he seemed like he was crazy anyway
and then and then you had David and
scabbit who I've never met him I don't
know anything about him but from the
book or the book so yeah well I'd be up
to five he's 5 for we got him yeah he's
tough though he's very strong but you
know I I it's not a very flattering
portrait of David Miscavige that guy's
book no no he seems like yes yeah but
having said that you know making fun of
Scientology's never been my thing
because like you said I'm sure there
that I know I know plenty of
Scientologists I went to acting class
with them acting class was featured in
the book I spent 10 years in that acting
class with Milken solid
the-the-the-the if you're gonna make fun
of Scientology you got to make fun of
all the other religions too and a lot
more bloodshed has been committed by the
other religions and in the name of those
other religions then in Scientology so I
think we should all be a little careful
yes I think what what baffles me is that
I know as you do many smart people and
then some of those things where I'm like
how how do you believe that like that's
word like it's not like you can believe
what you want to believe yeah but some
of the people you know the Mormons after
Scientology came along like that snake
doesn't seem so weird anymore does it
yeah its underwear that seems like you
know so much of religion is not even
about the faith it's it's you know the
mitts metaphor and I I think a lot of
Scientologists and Muslims and Jews and
Christians they identify as these
religions because there are two ways to
define and I'm gonna I'm gonna quote
Reza Aslan here
just google it yeah it's it's it's not
you know the two ways when you say
you're a Muslim or you say you're a
Christian there are practices and
beliefs that define you but then there's
another way to define it which is just
that you identify with a cultural sort
of glue that a lot of your people have
come up in it's a tradition there are
churches that maybe you go once a year
you celebrate Christmas doesn't make you
a die hard
you know literalist when it comes to the
Bible a Christian no and I think I
promise you I promise you
most Muslims are the same way I know if
I'm living in that part of the by the
way most of most religions like people
most people like that what I've always
said the beautiful thing about religion
is it gives people a sense of belonging
and a sense of inspiration in
communities yeah so when you anything
gets hijacked by extremism you're in
trouble you're you don't do any of this
stuff in your standup how is your
stand-up changed as you've gotten older
you talk about your kids life struggles
and so I you know we've had it's almost
opposite for me I don't because my kids
are older you know for a long time all
my set was all about kids it's
interesting for me to have almost
attacked life in an opposite way than
most people that I know in this town you
know I don't know it actually looked
I've always said the hardest things in
your life when you're going through them
are terrible looking back it's you know
they shape you into who you are yeah
excuse me so living in one bedroom with
three kids on $1,000 a month at the time
was terrible it's amazing looking back
it really was the best thing that has
happened to me can you think of a time
like that for you that was really
mentally for whatever reason yes I was
temping I was temping at 26 years old or
whatever it Goldman Sachs and I was
running coffee and making copies and I
wanted to be an actor and I would be in
a suit and tie and
be the summertime on a subway as I was
looking at the sweat gathering on my arm
I was a rolled up sleeve and I was on
the subway and I had been there it was 8
o'clock at night I had to be there late
doing some [ __ ] and I thought to
myself I don't think I'm ever going to
be a success I think I've failed I think
I went to acting school and now I'm I'm
trying to get jobs I think I had tried
to get and I called my agent said hey I
hear they're looking for Robin in the
new Batman movie and my agent said yeah
that's going to mark walberg or to call
Chris and I was like ok cool thanks man
like he was so he was just like 2,000
people bow out urine I remember looking
at myself in the mirror and I saw myself
on camera I was like it was just all I
was doomed to fail so stand-up was what
kind of changed everything got me mad TV
and all that but you know I've had
plenty of those I've had plenty of down
time I've had plenty of moments where I
feel like I really I still feel like I
failed but you you in the common theme
with a lot of people on my podcast is
what I respect about you is that you are
in constant hustle mode yeah constant
hustle mode yeah that's what I do
yes your aren't you are in costs so for
me like what is it is it the same Drive
that your quest your thirst for
knowledge is it the same reason or what
is it know Ives you say hustle mode for
me like I I love the process of
discovery I think writing for example is
I'm gonna stand still right now and I
know I'm gonna have a day if I keep
showing up where something's gonna show
itself to me explain to me showing up
like so so so I've quoted this a million
times but I'll say it a million one I'll
give you a couple examples Flannery
O'Connor and a lot of and Steven
Pressfield in this book the war war of
art or the war for art and going pro I
think is another book I read both those
books in and but Flannery O'Connor with
the great the great writer who died of
MS at 39 a woman in the 30s and
she said I sit at my typewriter every
morning at 5:30 not to write but in case
something happens it's always an act of
faith yeah and just keeps showing up man
keep selling up you know I've talked to
Fiona Apple I've talked to Bruce
Springsteen about this where I said how
do you write songs and they're like you
know you start with a metaphor and you
keep showing up that kind of reveals
itself to you the idea being that the
song already exists it's just up to you
to keep showing up have you ever been to
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame no okay
so if the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame in
Cleveland I have yeah so they have yeah
I say that because I I knew I had like
what comedy stand up in Cleveland
hilarity I went there yeah yes and so
that's why that's why I was like no then
I was like yeah I did cuz I had nothing
to do it I went there he what's funny is
people say have you ever been to this
city I'm like what comedy clubs there
exactly but I went to the Rock n Roll
Hall of Fame and I was with my son and
we were looking at these handwritten
notes of Beatles lyrics Springsteen
lyrics stones lyrics and I started to
tear up and it was like why basically he
said what the [ __ ] is wrong with you get
it together
yeah but I said he said why is that
affecting like that I said it's amazing
to me that John Lennon's process yours
yeah was the same as mine so so what's
the difference effort hours I don't yeah
I mean I don't know you saying I'm a
gentleman I've always considered you the
John that I come to my Paul McCartney
maybe I am a little darker yeah I I was
so inspired by that to know that the
process has never changed no it's a dude
in his room maybe with a joint or water
or whatever every comic every come on
cocked - Jeff Ross or Bill burr and this
the process doesn't get easier I will
tell you something by the way about burr
and this is something I've been
wrestling with and I don't know if
you've ever wrestled with this before
it's taking me a while I know what I do
well on stage I also kind of know what I
wish I did well does that make sense so
I look at Burr and Louie CK and Rogan
the way they attack
joke and they really they can take a
premise who they are though yes I know
you are
no but it's taking me a little while to
go look you see that guitar man one of
the reasons that I pushed out of
bringing a guitar and I bring it onstage
for the middle of my act now be you know
why it's fun I enjoy it yeah but it took
me so long to have the balls to go get
one and do it because what is my
instinct that other comics are gonna say
you [ __ ] pal you [ __ ] playing
guitar not me I'll punch him in the face
but you know what I mean I'm not
intimidated by any comics like that
that's my problem is that like louis c.k
bill burr i like bill very much but I
don't I'm not intimidated by any of
those guys because I I do my own thing I
never think of it as a competition no me
neither and also also though but when
did you settle into your who am I on I
don't know I never I mean I maybe I have
as a guy I'm always like I I just try to
be as original as I can and I'd only
write what I think is funny yeah and I
do well you know people seem to like me
but you know nobody's gonna tell me or
intimidate me especially a comic cuz you
know punch in the face tell me I mean so
you know I'm naked I don't um what what
is can you think of for you the last
time you wrote a joke in your house you
were like this is gonna [ __ ] kill and
you get on stage and you're like just
crickets the work that happened to me
recently when I told this big long story
that I was like oh this ending because
it was real and it was a natural
callback yeah it was gonna be I was
gonna be have to drop the mic and just
dab my head with a towel and take a sip
while people were clapping yeah yeah
yeah in my head so like you might have
been aiming though and I said it was
like yeah [ __ ] the jokes leading up to
the story huge the ending that I thought
was going to be a
yeah like you should be on HBO right now
yeah that did not happen yeah for me um
I do things if that like I've been doing
things some of the things that that's
kind of scare me because I'm not sure
how they're gonna come home and what I
do think it scares me it usually has the
reaction I'm looking for I'm afraid of
it but I commit to it and if you think
he's commit more when you're scared I
don't know maybe I think I do when I'm
not sure something I like doing things
I'm afraid of anyway like that's why I
box and I try to spar
I hate sparring because I'm it's not
like wrestling and jiu-jitsu that's ways
in a role boxing with like guys who can
hit you get hit in the head and it
really hurts and I'm not good enough to
not get hit in the head and I'm not good
enough too much so when I do it with
guys who are and Yusuf are usually with
a pro or something dude they can touch
you and it hurts and I just never like
yeah yeah yeah the guy you think he's a
good street fighter if he fights a boxer
he's going to sleep how many punches to
those guys can set you up that they can
do what's their precision like with a
punch
do you know what I mean they can break
your jaw the first thing I say it I'd
like to Chris mannered nor any that's
our Wayne McCullough when I would box
with them is these are world champions
I'd say dude just don't break my nose
don't break my job please and don't
[ __ ] drop me with a body shot they
can do anything they want right so
really they move around with you and you
get to throw shots yeah no don't slip
punches and you can't even hit them and
so you know and if they wanted to open
up even a good amateur amateur it's a
different game man
you know it's like why have you ever
wrestled Jitsu that doesn't krav maga
yeah but I promise you if you and I are
on I'm out I do whatever I want to
you've never done it it's no big deal
but I would it doesn't mean I stronger
tougher exactly but you would just not
know what to do so much and I would be
able to and I'm not you know I was a
wrestler but it doesn't mean it wasn't a
great fight or anything like that but
when you deal with a boxer who's been
doing it their whole life they see
everything you're doing before you do it
so there so they can chunk information
so oh look here comes his left and he's
gonna do a double jab well I just I'll
just slip that and just put a shot on it
on
on the like the top of his jaw and they
just touch you or maybe they just hit
you in the side of the head and you
weren't here yeah I wear a [ __ ] bar I
had no business doing this but it scares
me and when I'm done I it opens up a
bunch of other channels how old is your
son
four would you if he wanted to he was
like I want to be a boxer would you be a
boxer no he'll definitely learn would
you if he said I wanted to be a boxer
would you let it be about yeah I mean
probably um
even after talking to Tony Jefferies
yeah there I would I would let him
because I don't think my son my son
looks like he's gonna be athletic but
we're talking about a different I don't
think my kids gonna make their living as
athletes we don't have that genetics I
don't want to let them play football it
makes me scared because I don't think as
we know more and more about concussions
and things and I've talked to pro
football players won't let their kids
play yeah I don't like it it scares me
the game I love the game but I don't
want my son bashing heads it's an
interesting thing I let him wrestle and
do jiu-jitsu Oh what do you think those
cuz i when i was taking Krav Maga my
brain worked in a different way is that
what do you think those skills teach a
kid or person same thing is learning any
new language that's why the guitar is
great the drums are great anything that
requires you to think in a different way
I think and keeps you in in you're out
of your comfort zone it's just going to
what does that do because III tell
people I'm a huge believer in it me too
what do you think it does for people to
work outside of their comfort zone I
think it breaks down the mystery of life
I think it breaks down sort of like oh
that's not for me I can't do that
everything's a language it depends on
how fluent you are at that language jiu
jitsu is a language boxing's own
language guitar is a language and I
think um I think it's very very good to
do things you're not gonna because it
keeps you I think it probably opens up
new neural pathways yeah I think it
keeps you your skin thinner and you feel
life more people ask me all the time
what the best thing about stand-up is
and
I say for me at this point it's a great
combination of having a parachute but
not knowing if it's gonna work well
think about the people you admire the
people you admire state uncomfortable
the people you admire did things they
they were afraid of the people that you
would admire did what was considered
impossible mhm
you know when roger bannister broke the
four-minute mile or they're a thousand
examples but did that dude who has two
dicks they're both eight inches what he
has two dicks come on
two dicks both over eight inches see if
you know is it's not true you from that
you've never seen the double dictator no
but I don't think it's like the
double-double bit twins
he's got two dicks guy would I gotta see
this
I can't believe this is just coming up
now you really need to get on my email
chain because this was I I won't
I think you sent me an email of somebody
defecating on someone else's after all
this talk I am the guy with two penises
he was he pictures you just want to talk
to him I want to see pictures of
is there a safety thing on there must be
a safety thing on hold on I'm sorry let
me go back I don't know why there'd be
safety thing I'm I am the guy who two
penises my proof here we go there you go
dude with two dicks he really does have
two dicks yeah yeah he says that one is
one is gay and one is straight he says
that's incredible that he actually has
and not like two tiny dicks Alan that's
that's like a dick
that's not bad it's not the same but I
wonder what happens in that situation
well he says he's had sex with two
people at once that's incredible right
he said he's had sex with a man and a
woman at the same time well I mean did
you want to look at the picture any
longer no we're good congratulations for
not being circumcised he's got the whole
thing I know it's really an interesting
like if you if you just showed me a
picture of that and I glanced at it yeah
I would be like I mean that really is I
wonder why I didn't have one removed
would you yeah I think so
would you have it removed and add it on
well you know they can transplant
penises now is I would donate one to
charity would you pick your donor no I
mean it's a lot of soldiers it's
devastating but you know what these IEDs
they lose they're my oldest son was that
Afghan yeah well he was in the army army
yeah I don't know how you dealt with it
I would have flipped out every [ __ ]
day let me tell you what it is because
think about your boy right so when your
boy came into the world
automatically your first job in your
brain was like I'm keeping him safe yeah
that's your instinct yeah for me to have
him go and not be able to have any
control whether he was safe or not was
and not only that it's beyond and we're
gonna try to do this without crying but
you know when you Skype with him and you
know where he is yeah and you're not
allowed and he's everybody I know went
over there said
show fear do not show you you're nervous
you've got to be happy he's gonna click
on that screen well cuz he's got to show
you he's okay he's got enough to worry
about
yeah without you without him worrying
about you being worried yeah and you
know when you go a day and you don't
hear or two days you're hear from them
it's yeah it's just too long it changes
and I think about the parents and the
brothers and who deal with guys who come
back and girls who come back with no
arms or who are just never the same and
that's why I you know if you're gonna go
to war you better do it for the right
reason I don't I don't you know I don't
get into that but I it's 70,000 I think
we have 70,000 veterans who are 70
percent or more disabled and that's an
unacceptable number seriously you know
it's what happens with the VA now well
this the service and the medical
attention that the vets are getting is
just not up to par in and it
what is baffling is that we spend so
much time training these soldiers we
kill we put so much time and energy into
making sure that when they get over
there they're prepared but we don't put
the same amount of time and energy to
make sure when they come back they're
just as taken care of right and and it's
like it's it's been that way for a long
time and they think yeah it's always
been I think you'd find veterans of
every war I was a similar gripe I don't
wanna use the word gripe because it's
more than that it's a legit you know
complaint and again you're talking about
[ __ ] that makes me crazy because I can't
control it I can't fix it but that's why
as I look as a is that one of the
reasons you think you work out as hard
as you do you because you're to control
things I mean you can't can oh I just
work out because I I like the way it
makes me feel I mean you know I work out
because I don't want
I ever I workout because I can yeah I
you know I love Ito portal I don't know
if you know it means this Israeli
movement specialist move because you can
you know what are your movement patterns
you know he's great that's what I love I
like to move I'm very kinetic I can't
sit still
do you energy do you when you say that
you like you want to live forever I know
you said that jokingly but is that like
is that a concern do you wake up every
morning is that a concern of yours that
you're getting older in this town yes
that's you know that's so human-like
again not to bring up Socrates but you
know what what is how do you define love
and he said we you've got to define love
of what is man trail of immortality
there's no one in the world doesn't want
to live forever that's where your kids
are so important to you that's where
your work is so important you because
you're leaving a mark we all want to be
significant we all want to leave a mark
if we do it to our progeny or we do its
who are you know building the Taj Mahal
or painting the Sistine Chapel whatever
it might be doing a podcast we all want
to be relevant yes okay interesting
question for you how do you want your
son to think of you well it's a goddamn
great question and it's what I'm writing
about it's such a good question I can
tell you for me and I've I've thought
about it for me it seems really simple I
want them to want I want them to be
proud this is so simple of Who I am
yeah it's so simple I want them to look
at me and go he did this the way I think
they will with you and I think they will
with me because we made the right
choices we made the big choices um yeah
I want my son you know what I want to
teach my son I want to teach my son to
laugh at himself mm-hmm not take himself
too seriously I want him to teach I want
to teach him to be self-reliant and
resilient Gillian's huge thing yeah I'll
set an example and I'll [ __ ] up and
you know and but I I want my son to
think you know what the main thing is I
want my son to know I love the [ __ ] out
of him and my daughter too that's thing
number one yeah
how old's your daughter seven thing
number one and to me the most important
thing is to know they love they're loved
and then it's up to you I've said this a
million times and I wrote it in my book
look for every good thing you do as a
parent there is an opposite there's
something bad that comes out of that hmm
there just is there's no perfect parent
so so if you talk about this parent is
so organized and has their kid well that
you know that kid who structured their
entire life when they leave the house
that may not be good for ya because now
they're in [ __ ] freefall that's right
right let's you know you can be a lot of
wealthy kids they're not ready for the
real not ready but I will tell you like
for me when you teach your kids that
they're loved most important thing but
then like you have to decide what's
important to you like recently my son
got his first card and people are like
would you buy him I tell you what about
him nothing that's not my job to buy him
I want because if I buy him a car he
doesn't appreciate it he has a 2004 Kia
cuz that's what he could afford Yeah
right now a lot of people like what on
this whole movie would buy it's great I
just don't for me that for me well [ __ ]
him for my son what was your 18 I got a
Honda Civic when my son's 18 he's gonna
[ __ ] get whatever happens to be there
I'm not no yeah for me it was like
you've already annoyed at him wait till
he starts jerking off in the shower oh
that's awesome Christ that's the thing
about my son
my daughter's a complete mystery my son
I understand everything I know that
[ __ ] kid that's what I said a million
times no am i hey we have the same
interest I haven't grown at all since I
was four he's in this round smooth
surfaces for eating and fighting you
know penetrating yeah same thing my son
actually I was in his room this was
before he went up over to college and I
was walking to talk to him and he saw me
walk around things and I he goes what
are you doing I go I'm not stepping on
those socks and he goes why not I go
just in case because I was a teenage boy
who jerked off in my bed and threw the
sock and the floral jerking off right
right so but I agree my daughter I had
the same problems man because I don't
know her path all I know is that I know
dudes my age yeah and I knew what they
would try to do right so I told her you
can't believe a [ __ ] word anybody at
the end the age of 25 ever says see my
daughter you know again she's like seven
she's into the unicorns twirling and
braids you know I don't know I don't
speak that language but you know what I
do I make her laugh I crack her up and I
am her playmate and that's and I'm her
protector and I'll protect her all right
I know you've had a long day and we've
been here for a little while thank you
for having me my friend buddy
come see me are you gonna winter you
when you airing this I will download it
tonight come to the American comedy club
New Year's in San Diego I'll be there
for a seven o'clock and a 10 o'clock
show what a great club the American
comedy company yes San Diego now also
your podcast the Brian can't no I'm
sorry the fighter and the kid not
anymore the fighter and the kid which is
with Brennan shop and it's uh even for
people who are not fight fans I would
tell you tune in it's it's fun
well-rounded fun we try to keep it well
rounded and funny and then anything else
any other road things you want talking
about that's it LeAnn Vancouver I think
we're already almost sold out but
Vancouver January something something
and we have the tour tour tickets are
still available in Seattle go to tea fat
K T fat K calm that stands for the fire
in the kid yeah calm tea fat K calm
before tickets we still have tickets
left for Seattle and Portland some for
San Diego House of Blues I think January
14th and some for Las Vegas January 20
minutes or something selling it's crazy
place out months ahead of Pizza nuts to
die I am telling you it's nuts
yes months ahead of time we already sold
out at The Comedy Store let's still some
tickets left I think for February 4th we
sold we've already sold 100
eighty tickets to The Comedy Store
[ __ ] crazy yeah um guys am i I'll
just give you what I'm doing in January
January I'm in Kansas City the first
week Buffalo then Craig Glaser
yeah leisure so I'm in I'm in his office
and crating Greg calls me Anand and he
goes hey
and I go yeah and there was a girl sent
to the desk I think what's going on he
was just I just got to know before the
weekend you [ __ ] teenagers and I go
anyways do you [ __ ] teenagers I go no I
don't [ __ ] teenagers he goes you don't
[ __ ] teenagers I go no that's illegal
and he was like okay and like I was the
weird up yeah like I was like he's a
character Craig is a Greg's carry a book
that's a good kick though I like I like
Kansas City always ever could always had
good rooms Buffalo helium and then
Portland helium and then Boston la
vigilia Marco some of those guys and the
left Boston Club is amazing fantastic
and I'll be there and guys other good
[ __ ] coming Thank You Man thank you for
being here the best brother always so
happy it's so happy
it's so happy so happy it's so happy
that's so happy so happy so happy